Antwerp is Belgium's biggest harbour and
Europe's second largest seaport located
at the mouth of the skell River the
origins of Antwerp s-- name are unclear
some say it stems from unter therefore
at the wharf others claim it's from aunt
V up the alluvial mound where early
settlers lived then there's the legend
of purple dating back to the 15th
century a hero named purple lopped off
the hand of a giant and threw it into
the sea creating the mouth of the Scout
this hunt weapon or hand throwing became
London or Antwerp even today the symbol
of the hand appears repeatedly in
Antwerp the town is also known as the
center of the global diamond trade the
art of gem cutting still takes place
behind closed doors artworks abound this
statue of Peter Paul Rubens remembers
the Flemish painter who had a studio
here
Ruben's friends in our blood here in
Antwerp the remarkable man lived here it
already became a tourist attraction in
his lifetime the Rubens Museum is
located in his former home some of the
Flemish masters paintings as well as his
private collection of works by his
contemporaries can be seen here but
there are many more museums in Antwerp
some of them have recently been
relocated together in a new building
near the port it's called the museum
under strom or mass for short
the muscles a new museum about the city
of Antwerp the Port of Antwerp and
connections with all different corners
of the world through the port of entry
visiting and permanent exhibitions about
the history of the poor a shown on the
museum's eight levels apart from the
items on display some four hundred and
seventy thousand items from maritime
history are stored here
the large windows give visitors a view
of the tall ships that anchor here from
time to time Antwerp is also firmly on
the fashion map with all of the big
brands represented here fashion and
design looms large all over the city
here for example at con marked 13 this
floor you have the shop where you can
buy clothes but also objects changing
exhibitions of internationally renowned
art are held on the first floor there's
also a gourmet restaurant in the
basement creative types tend to collect
just outside Antwerp storage center
German designer
Anya Schwab ah is among those who found
a niche in Antwerp you've got one pool
that's really chic and another that's
really alternative I'm somewhere between
one of these niches
she makes clothes for children and
adults so how did she start sort of
things they start somehow making the
first items from your grandmother's old
sheets and honestly that's how it
started
Antwerp has long been a European capital
of fashion the Antwerp fashion Museum or
Mamu gives visitors a look at the long
history of the city's creative
relationship to clothing and those who
long to wear the latest designs at
work's architecture also draws visitors
from around the globe they enjoy
relaxing in the city's many cafes and
Antwerp isn't just a port city it is
also home to one of Europe's most
beautiful railway stations